you think that's fighting the biggest
bird in the world would be quite
straightforward
turns out snow
here he comes
[Music]
that
is the biggest third on the planet
each one of those wings
is as wide as i am told the wandering
albatrosses wingspan is over 11 feet
wide
i mean just imagine living life like
that
you know flying thousands and thousands
of miles
all by yourself i mean that said some of
them are coming back to land to breed at
the moment
and that's when they reveal a totally
different side of their personalities
[Applause]
[Music]
how is it possible that life can come
back from the dead
the island of south georgia was the
scene of one of the worst wildlife
massacres in history
species driven to near extinction
the whaling stations were abandoned
this is an awe-inspiring story of how if
given the chance
nature can bounce back on a scale you're
not going to believe
my name's bertie gregory and i'm a
national geographic wildlife filmmaker
[Music]
this
is resurrection island
this place is so much like jurassic park
i kind of feel like we're going to get
picked off by a velociraptor at any
moment
the only difference is the velociraptors
are a lot fatter a bit more grumpy and
they're called fur seals
didn't seem very pleased to see us
[Music]
look at that review
[Music]
don't call it wanderer ridge for nothing
the sky up here is filled with wonders
and they're just so at home in the wind
i mean everything here is huge the birds
are huge the ocean's huge the mountains
are huge
the wind is huge it makes filming really
difficult
whilst massive wind speeds would deter
most from coming anywhere near bird
island it's exactly why these birds are
here
they need the wind to thrive
it gives them the boost to get their
giant bodies into the air
whoa coming in
oh it's like sitting on the end of a
runway waiting for a 747 to come in
for as graceful as these birds are in
the air they're terrestrial landings
well
they're more like crash landings
this is the reason
that they've come all the way back to
land
some of the adults coming back here are
coming back to find their mate that
they've been with for decades
but
these guys haven't read before they're
first-time breeders
so they're kind of on a first date
and for that reason they've got to do a
bit of showing off they've got to make a
good impression
at around 10 years of age young males
reach sexual maturity
they'll then take a stand on a nest and
start trying to attract a mate
and they make for life so if an
albatross can live 60 years they don't
want to just waste it on anyone
after all it's a relationship that lasts
longer than most human marriages
the wandering albatross courtship has so
many different layers to it and you can
see there's a lot of posturing moving
back and forth they've got their wings
out it's a bit of build fencing where
they tap their bills together
he's vibrating his beat you hear that
weird alien noise
and the other thing he's doing is sky
calling when he points his head
straight into the sky and makes that
amazing screaming noise
[Music]
i love it when timing works out
[Music]
[Applause]
once a pair start getting into it more
and more try to join the party
this is one of the most elaborate
courtship rituals in the animal kingdom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after what could be years of courting
the albatross mates are finally ready to
take their next step in life
starting a family
[Music]
yeah that's it
[Music]
[Music]
once the bond is formed they'll soon
learn to rely on each other
for the rest of their lives
you know it's so easy to get the wrong
idea with these guys you know when you
see them flying out over the open ocean
you think that they're just these lone
rangers but there's so much more to
their lives than that
[Music]
they form this amazing long-term bond
their relationships all about
dedication partnership
since they only lay one egg every two
years they put a huge amount of time and
resources into raising just a single
chick
and they divvy up the chores like
building and maintaining their nest
then once the female has laid the egg
the pair will take turns incubating
while the other heads out to sea for
some lunch
say as far as brazil
that's a 5 000 mile round trip which
they do in just two weeks
now the key to traveling all that
distance is the way that it flies
it does this amazing zigzagging pattern
what it's doing is it's turning up into
wind it's gaining gravitational
potential energy it gains altitude when
it reaches the peak it then turns in the
direction that it wants to travel and
gains kinetic energy it turns that
potential energy into forwards momentum
and then just as it's about to run out
of height and clip the surface of the
water it turns back up into the wind and
gains all that altitude again and it
just does that over and over again so it
can fly miles and miles and miles
without ever needing to flap its wings
[Music]
although this technique of dynamic
soaring is the very thing that makes
albatrosses the most well-traveled birds
in the world
it also brings them into dangerous
waters where commercial fisheries
practice unsafe long line fishing
methods
albatross see the bait they dive on it
and swallow the hook
and today their populations are in peril
but there is hope
and that's because with a few simple
changes in fishing practices we can
avoid the albatross getting killed by
these hooks and that's been done with
great success around here the island of
south georgia where the bycatch has been
reduced to pretty much zero
[Music]
whilst this local success is great news
their ability to wander means that only
with international cooperation can we
ensure the future of the wandering
albatross
[Music]
[Music]
you